Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour et
bienvenue dans "Parlement hebdo".
Les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
sous le regard de notre invité.
- Alexandre Poussart: On accueille
Loïc Hervé.
Vous êtes sénateur de la
Haute-Savoie et membre du groupe
centriste au Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder: Beaucoup
d'actualité pour vous, Loïc Hervé.
Les questions après la démission
du maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins.
L'élu été la cible de menaces.
Sa maison et sa voiture ont été
incendiées.
Il soutenait un projet de
transfert d'un centre de migrants
dans sa commune.
Une commission d'enquête
parlementaire pour faire la
lumière sur le fonds Marianne créé
en 2011 par Marlène Schiappa pour
lutter contre le séparatisme.
Au coeur de l'affaire: des
soupçons de détournement d'argent
public.
Et puis le drapeau européen divise
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Une proposition de loi qui oblige
les communes de plus de 1500
habitants à afficher le drapeau
sur les mairies.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le maire de
Loire-Atlantique a démissionné
sous la pression et la violence de
l'extrême droite.
Députés et sénateurs ont exprimé
leur indignation.
- Nous apprenons la démission de
Yannick Morez, le maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins, victime de
ce qu'il qualifie être un
terrorisme d'extrême droite.
Son domicile a été incendié parce
qu'il défendait l'installation
d'un centre d'accueil de
demandeurs d'asile.
Des événements de cette nature
nous interpellent.
Applaudissements
- Je suis profondément inquiète et
profondément préoccupée que, dans
notre pays, des gens puissent,
d'une manière aussi lâche, aussi
violente, s'en prendre à une
personne qui a une autorité, qui
exerce son autorité, qui a été élu
par ses concitoyens et qui fait
juste son job de maire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous êtes
aussi président délégué de
l'Association des petites villes
de France.
Comment vous réagissez à la
démission de ce maire sous la
violence de l'extrême droite?
- Loïc Hervé: Ce qui se passe est
extrêmement grave.
L'effet de l'incendie du domicile
de ce maire date de quelques mois.
Mais surtout, ce cri d'alarme...
Nous allons le recevoir au Sénat
dans quelques jours.
Ce cri d'alarme, c'est la
manifestation d'un maire qui n'en
peut plus.
Il a eu peur pour lui-même, pour
sa famille.
J'ai moi-même vécu cette situation
de menaces de mort.
J'ai été protégé pendant près d'un
mois par la gendarmerie.
C'est extrêmement dur à vivre
pour vous-même, et pour votre
famille.
Donc l'émotion est forte.
Par rapport aux faits qui se sont
produits, par rapport à sa
démission.
J'entendais qu'on pourrait
éventuellement renforcer encore le
droit pénal.
Je pense qu'on touche...
On a fait dans ce pays un tabou le
fait que finalement, s'en prendre
à des élus, c'est pas si choquant
que ça.
L'émotion est légitime, notamment
à gauche.
Je la partage.
Mais je pense qu'on devrait être
beaucoup plus solidaires et
beaucoup plus aux côtés de ce
maire qui démissionne.
Il faut marquer qu'il n'est pas
possible de s'en prendre à un
maire.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que pour
vous, il n'a pas été assez
protégé?
- Alexandre Poussart: Par l'Etat?
- Loïc Hervé: Je peux pas parler
de...
Je n'en sais rien.
Il nous dira quand il sera entendu
par la commission des lois.
Quand j'ai été concerné, j'ai été
protégé.
Bernard Cazeneuve et le préfet de
département, m'ont protégé, ont
mis les mesures nécessaires.
Le sujet, ce sont aussi ces
groupuscules.
Le maire en question, c'est des
militants et des groupuscules
d'extrême droite qui s'en sont
pris à lui.
Pour moi, c'était plutôt la
mouvance salafiste.
Pour d'autres, ce seront des
mouvements d'extrême gauche.
- Kathia Gilder: Comment on fait
pour contrer la puissance de ces
groupuscules?
On a l'impression que les lois ne
suffisent pas.
- Loïc Hervé: Il y a le droit
pénal, une fois qu'on a confondu
les auteurs.
Et il y a la prévention.
Dans cette commune, on a laissé
régulièrement se faire des
manifestations contre le maire.
Ce sont des personnes qui n'ont
rien
à voir avec la commune et le maire
avait demandé que ces
manifestations soient interdites
et elles ne l'ont pas été.
Il faudrait que l'on regarde de
manière objective comment la
Commission des lois va entendre ce
maire.
Il faudra demander des comptes aux
ministres concernés sur le fait
qu'on laisse, dans une commune...
Il s'agit d'un transfert de centre
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est ça qui a
généré tout ça.
- Loïc Hervé: Pour les élus
locaux, la gestion des centres
d'accueil, c'est très compliqué.
L'association des élus locaux est
très relative par rapport à ces
structures.
Il y a des éléments très concrets
dans l'administration de ces
sujets sur le territoire qu'il
faut revoir.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce qu'il
faut des mesures supplémentaires
pour protéger nos élus?
- Loïc Hervé: On a voté au Sénat,
à plusieurs reprises, y compris
dans la loi de programmation dont
j'étais le rapporteur au Sénat, et
il y a des mesures de droit pénal
à prendre.
Mais je pense qu'il y a des
mesures de prévention, je le
redis.
Quand une situation est délétère
et se cristallise sur une personne
dans une commune, il faut pas
attendre que le domicile du maire
soit incendié.
Il faut pas attendre qu'il
démissionne.
- Kathia Gilder: Les pouvoirs
publics ont trop attendu?
- Loïc Hervé: Je pense qu'on a
trop laissé traîner les choses.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat a
voté cette semaine en faveur de la
création d'une commission
d'enquête sur le fonds Marianne
avec l'objectif de faire la
lumière sur sa gestion.
Il a été créé en 2021 par Marlène
Schiappa contre la radicalisation
en ligne.
Les sénateurs doivent faire
attention à ne pas empiéter sur
l'enquête judiciaire qui est
également ouverte.
- Validée à l'unanimité par la
commission des lois du Sénat, la
création de la commission
d'enquête sur le fonds Marianne va
chercher à comprendre comment ont
été attribuées les subventions aux
diverses aux associations qui en
ont bénéficié.
Le président de la commission des
finances à l'initiative de cette
commission d'enquête a une
multitude de questions.
- Comment s'est créé le fonds
Marianne?
Qui en a eu l'idée?
Comment il a été monté?
Comment le choix des associations
et selon quels critères?
- Le fonds Marianne a été créé en
2021 par Marlène Schiappa après
l'assassinat du professeur Samuel
Paty.
Doté de 2,5 millions d'euros,
alloués à 17 associations, pour
lutter contre les phénomènes de
radicalisation et promouvoir les
valeurs de la République.
Une enquête journalistique avait
pointé du doigt la gestion opaque
de ce fonds public.
- On est le pays au monde, dans le
monde développé, où on a le plus
d'impôts, de prélèvements et de
dépenses publiques.
- Le parquet national financier a
ouvert une information judiciaire
pour des soupçons de détournement
de fonds publics, abus de
confiance et prise illégale
d'intérêts.
Une procédure en parallèle de la
création de la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale.
- Nous ne savions pas si le
parquet national financier allait
de lui-même engager une démarche.
Nous avons eu le pif.
- Les sénateurs devront prendre
garde à ne pas marcher sur les
plates-bandes du parquet national
financier pour la commission
d'enquête débutera ses travaux
mardi prochain avec l'audition du
secrétaire général du comité
interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la
radicalisation.
Le Sénat s'est donné trois mois
pour rendre ses conclusions sur le
fonds Marianne.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat a
une raison de lancer cette
commission d'enquête?
- Loïc Hervé: Bien sûr.
Chaque fois qu'un centime d'argent
public ne va pas à l'endroit pour
lequel le Parlement a décidé qu'il
aille, chaque fois qu'il y a un
risque ou un soupçon de
détournement de fonds publics sur
des questions aussi graves...
On vient de parler d'un maire qui
a été victime de violences.
Tous ces sujets sont connexes.
Il s'agit d'argent public, là.
La presse a fait son travail.
La justice est en train de faire
le sien.
Le Parlement contre l'action des
ministres au nom du peuple.
Les députés et les sénateurs,
quand ils créent une commission
d'enquête, quand ils demandent des
comptes à des fonctionnaires de
l'emploi de ces fonds publics, les
sénateurs sont absolument dans
leur rôle constitutionnel, comme
les députés.
On a oublié cette fonction de
contrôle parlementaire.
Une commission d'enquête
parlementaire, c'est ça.
- Kathia Gilder: Elle a beaucoup
de pouvoir, cette commission.
Néanmoins, elle ne peut pas
interférer, empiéter sur l'enquête
judiciaire.
C'est possible à faire?
Ca ne risque pas d'interférer, par
moment?
- Loïc Hervé: On a déjà eu des
cas, notamment l'affaire Benalla,
qui a été la plus médiatisée, et
de la même manière, une enquête
judiciaire qui a été diligentée.
Il faut être très vigilant pour
que les magistrats et les
parlementaires puissent faire leur
travail.
Sur la création de ce fonds, les
décisions prises qui ont été
évoquées, la manière dont l'argent
a été orienté vers des
associations, de quelle manière,
et le contrôle a posteriori...
Quand vous faites un choix pour
donner de l'argent, vous devez
faire un contrôle après-coup.
Est-ce que tout ça a été fait dans
les règles de l'art?
Je pense que la commission des
finances pourra faire son travail.
Je connais bien les parlementaires
qui sont en charge de cette
enquête.
Je suis sûr qu'ils seront très
vigilants à bien respecter les
compétences de la justice.
- Alexandre Poussart: Marlène
Schiappa est concernée par cette
affaire.
En tant que ministre de la
Citoyenneté en 2021, elle avait
lancé ce fonds et elle est
maintenant en charge du secteur
associatif.
Elle peut rester en poste?
- Loïc Hervé: C'est pas à moi d'en
décider, c'est au président de
décider de qui compose le
gouvernement du pays.
Marlène Schiappa a un peu disparu
des radars, un peu pour des
raisons personnelles qui ont fait
qu'une partie importante de son
portefeuille ministériel lui a été
retirée.
Dans un gouvernement, quand il y a
des difficultés de cet ordre et
des soupçons qui sont importants,
il me semble que le président et
la Première ministre en tirent
toutes les conséquences.
- Kathia Gilder: On va en parler
dans notre sujet.
Faut-il rendre obligatoire le
pavoisement du drapeau européen
sur le fronton des mairies?
Les députés ont voté cette
proposition de loi présentée par
le groupe Renaissance, mais seules
les communes de plus de 1500
habitants seront concernées.
Le vote a eu lieu à l'issue d'une
longue séance mouvementée que l'on
vous résume.
- C'est le drapeau de la discorde,
la bannière européenne.
Le groupe Renaissance veut le
rendre obligatoire sur les
mairies, à côté du drapeau
français.
Aujourd'hui, c'est l'usage, ce
n'est pas une obligation.
Cette idée a provoqué des débats
tendus à l'Assemblée.
Pour les insoumis, c'est une
proposition inutile.
- C'est un sujet de diversion.
Quand les Français apprennent
qu'on est en train de parler du
drapeau européen plutôt que de
parler de la question du pouvoir
d'achat, des salaires, de
l'inflation, de la retraite à 60
ans et non pas à 64, ou bien
encore de la VIe République, les
Français se demandent ce que font
les députés.
- Le Rassemblement National s'est
livré à une attaque en règle.
- Vous avez imposé dans nos rues
et dans nos mairies, sur vos
ministères, dans cet hémicycle, ce
drapeau contre la volonté du
peuple.
Vous méprisez le peuple français!
- Dans l'hémicycle, le débat a été
élargi: pour ou contre la
construction européenne?
Les oppositions ont été renvoyées
dos à dos.
- Ceux qui ont du mal à masquer
leur malaise face au drapeau
étoilé ont autant de mal à masquer
leur rêve de Frexit déguisé en
rouge pour les uns et en brun pour
les autres.
- Le député a fait adopter sa
proposition de loi.
Le Parti Socialiste l'a votée, pas
Les Républicains, qui ironisent
sur une "proposition édulcorée".
Elle ne concernera que les
communes de plus de 1500 habitants
pour ne pas alourdir
le budget des villages.
- Le symbole existe où il n'existe
pas.
On a failli avoir un symbole à
3500 habitants.
Il est finalement à 1500.
C'est quoi, ces symboles qui sont
négociables?
- Alors que les députés ont
débattu pendant cinq heures de ces
propositions, 78% des communes ne
seront pas concernées par cette
obligation.
- Kathia Gilder: Plus de 70% des
communes ne seront pas concernés
par cette obligation.
Ce qui a été voté a du sens?
- Loïc Hervé: Non.
Je suis européen, j'aime son
drapeau et son hymne.
J'ai été militant de l'Europe
fédérale, du mouvement européen
depuis toujours.
Je trouve irresponsable, dans
notre situation, de lancer un tel
débat.
Le drapeau européen, qui est très
beau, est très présent dans la vie
quotidienne des Français.
L'extrême droite le dénonce, ça ne
me surprend pas.
Mais il y a beaucoup de mairie en
France qui ont un drapeau européen
sur leur façade, quelle que soit
leur taille.
Etait-il nécessaire, dans la
tension actuelle du pays, de
lancer un tel débat à l'Assemblée
nationale?
C'est irresponsable.
En plus, ça fait porter un débat
sur cette relation d'un peuple, le
peuple français, à la construction
européenne, à l'histoire
européenne.
Le 9 mai 2023, on avait plutôt
besoin de concorde, de symboles
positifs, plutôt qu'un débat de ce
type qui va créer des obligations
aux maires.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est contraire
au principe de la
libre-administration des communes?
- Loïc Hervé: Les maires en ont
ras le bol qu'on leur impose des
normes supplémentaires, a fortiori
dans le domaine symbolique.
Ils sont aujourd'hui plutôt
préoccupés par d'autres réalités
liées aux finances locales, à la
mise en place de tout un tas de
lois qui sont encore difficiles.
Les questions d'assainissement
sont quelque chose de très
concret.
Si on pouvait laisser le drapeau
européen au sommet de sa mâture,
ce serait responsable.
Là, c'est irresponsable d'avoir
lancé ce débat.
Alors que l'Europe traverse une
situation compliquée, il faut...
Si on veut sauver l'Union
Européenne, il faut revenir à ses
fondamentaux, ceux de ses pères
fondateurs et avoir quelque chose
de positif, et pas ce type de
débat complètement décalé par
rapport à la réalité des élus et
des Français.
- Kathia Gilder: S'il venait au
Sénat, vous ne le voterez pas?
- Loïc Hervé: En tant que militant
européen, alors que j'ai toujours
eu le drapeau européen en tant que
maire, et il est toujours sur la
façade de la mairie de ma ville,
je ne voterais pas ce type
d'obligations.
Ce n'est pas sain.
- Kathia Gilder: On va parler dans
notre sujet, le projet de loi
immigration.
Après l'avoir rapporté à
l'automne, le gouvernement veut
présenter son texte au mois de
juillet.
Il lance une série de
consultations des parlementaires.
Les Républicains vont déposer des
propositions de loi.
- Nous prenons nos
responsabilités.
Le gouvernement l'a sans doute vu.
C'est pour cela qu'il use d'une
forme de revirement multiple.
On n'y comprend plus rien.
Les jours pairs, il y a un texte,
les jours impairs, il y en a un
autre.
Les bonnes propositions seront
dans le texte des Républicains.
Dans le texte de nature
constitutionnelle et dans celui
qui relève d'une loi simple.
- Vous retrouverez un certain
nombre de points qu'on a déjà
votés.
Par exemple, la transformation de
l'aide médicale d'Etat en aide
médicale d'urgence pour
restreindre le palier de soins.
Bien d'autres dispositions, aussi.
Il y aura un texte de loi
constitutionnel.
On touchera à la possibilité de
l'article 11 d'avoir, dans le
champ du référendum législatif, la
question migratoire.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
pourriez voter ces propositions de
loi?
Elles veulent durcir la politique
migratoire en diminuant l'aide
médicale d'Etat.
- Loïc Hervé: Avant de les voter,
j'aimerais les connaître.
Et deuxièmement, j'aimerais vous
dire que, si le groupe des
Républicains à l'Assemblée ou au
Sénat va faire des propositions,
le groupe de l'Union centriste va
en faire également.
Peut-être que nous avons une
approche sur les questions
migratoires qui est un peu plus
mesurée.
Notamment face à la situation
démographique et la situation de
l'emploi dans le pays.
J'ai entendu Bruno Retailleau dire
que l'immigration n'était plus une
chance pour la France.
On comprend déjà la tonalité que
Les Républicains veulent donner à
ce débat.
Au groupe de l'Union centriste,
s'il y a des propositions qui sont
bonnes, nous les voterons, mais
nous aurons nos propositions.
Philippe Bonnecarrère est un des
rapporteurs du texte qui a été
retiré par le gouvernement.
Nous aurons l'occasion, dans les
semaines qui viennent, de poser
nos jalons et nos sujets de débat
avec nos collègues des
Républicains.
Mais aussi avec des propositions
qui seront les nôtres.
- Alexandre Poussart: Quelles
propositions des sénateurs
centristes, par exemple?
L'immigration est une chance pour
la France, pour vous?
- Loïc Hervé: C'est le vieux
débat.
La question de la maîtrise de
l'immigration est une question
centrale.
Nous avons aujourd'hui trop
d'immigrés irréguliers qui
arrivent dans notre pays et sur le
territoire de l'Union Européenne.
La régulation est une bonne chose
en soi.
En revanche, nous avons une
situation de l'emploi qui est
tendue.
Je viens de Haute-Savoie, donc je
peux en parler d'expérience.
Il y a des situations de tension
dans lesquelles l'immigration peut
être une solution à un certain
nombre de nos métiers en tension.
C'était toute la partie Dussopt du
projet de loi qui a été déposé par
le gouvernement.
- Alexandre Poussart: Régulariser
les travailleurs sans-papiers dans
les secteurs en tension.
- Loïc Hervé: C'est une situation
très difficile à faire comprendre.
Ca aurait envoyé un message qui
était pas forcément celui qu'on
attendait.
Pour m'être rendu le week-end
dernier en Italie et la semaine
d'avant au Québec, je peux vous
assurer qu'un certain nombre de
nos voisins ou de pays dont nous
sommes proches ont une approche de
l'immigration beaucoup plus
pragmatique que la nôtre.
Donc pas d'idéologie, là-dessus.
La lutte contre les filières, la
lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine,
évidemment, mais soyons
raisonnables sur la question de
notre réalité du marché de
l'emploi.
Nous sommes en tension dans
beaucoup de métiers.
Il faut que nous ayons une
capacité de répondre à ça.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous soutenez
l'idée d'un référendum sur
l'immigration?
Ce serait une bonne ou une
mauvaise idée?
- Loïc Hervé: Avec la culture
plébiscitaire du référendum dans
notre pays, non.
Le référendum, c'est répondre par
oui ou par non à une question
complexe.
Un projet de loi dit aux Français:
"Voilà le projet, c'est oui ou
non."
Le travail d'écriture de la loi
est entre les mains des
parlementaires, du gouvernement,
qui viennent faire des
modifications ensuite.
Un texte aussi complexe, qui va
toucher tout un tas de domaines,
des questions de police, de
justice, d'économie, doit être
travaillé par les parlementaires.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va finir
cette émission par un sujet qui
préoccupe beaucoup de jeunes: le
passage du permis de conduire.
Il est de plus en plus difficile
de le passer.
Cela coûte cher.
Pour faciliter l'obtention du
permis, le Sénat a voté mercredi
une proposition de loi venue de
l'Assemblée nationale qui recense
toutes les aides financières pour
passer son permis.
Le compte personnel de formation
permettra de financer tous les
permis de conduire.
Les délais seront encore
raccourcis.
Vous étiez rapporteurs de ce texte
au Sénat.
Ca va vraiment changer la
situation?
- Loïc Hervé: Les mesures de la
proposition de loi que le Sénat a
modifiée, et la proposition de loi
a été adoptée cette semaine, ce
sont des mesures qui sont
attendues et qui sont les
bienvenues.
On aurait pu imaginer un débat
plus large sur la question du grand
âge. Sur la question des visites
médicales, notamment pour nos
compatriotes seniors, et sur la
question du permis à vie.
On aurait pu avoir un débat
profond sur la conduite
accompagnée.
A l'échelle d'une proposition de
loi, c'est difficile de porter le
débat en n'ayant pas tous les
éléments, notamment ceux des
études d'impact.
Pardon, mais l'agenda...
On n'a que quelques jours pour
préparer ce texte.
Avec mes collègues de la
commission des lois, j'ai regardé
le texte avec bienveillance.
On a fait quelques propositions de
modifications qui ont été
adoptées.
Ces mesures pourront entrer
rapidement en vigueur pour
l'élargissement des différents
permis, et sur la lutte contre la
fraude.
Et cette plate-forme va permettre
à un jeune, en rentrant son code
postal, d'avoir droit à toutes les
aides.
C'est près de 1600 euros en
moyenne pour passer le permis et
pour les familles, c'est très
cher.
Et on a pu parler jeunesse et
parler aux jeunes.
- Kathia Gilder: Message entendu.
On va terminer avec un regard
rapide sur l'ordre du jour à
venir.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi, au
Sénat, la commission d'enquête sur
l'affaire du fonds Marianne va
annoncer ses auditions.
Les sénateurs vont s'intéresser au
rôle du comité interministériel de
prévention de la délinquance et de
la radicalisation.
Mardi toujours, une autre
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur
la pénurie de médicaments va
auditionner les anciens ministres
de la Santé Xavier Bertrand et
Marisol Touraine.
Mercredi, les sénateurs vont
auditionner le maire qui a choisi
de démissionner.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée,
les députés vont voter une
proposition de loi contre les
méga-incendies.
Il y aura un projet de loi visant
à accélérer la création de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci
d'avoir été notre invité.
- Kathia Gilder: A bientôt.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA